what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so normally when I go through and I
run through like these these stories I
usually try to like do them in
chronological order but at all honesty
the perfect storm story arc wasn't
wildly interesting to me there were cool
elements of it and we can cover it if
you guys really really want to see it
but I actually think this is cooler I
think this like road to flash war is a
lot more interesting because I think
what this does is it answers a lot of
questions or at least it it really kind
of brings out a lot of intrigue with
regards to like what's going on in the
flash mythos how it ties into dr.
Manhattan in the Watchmen as well as
like the back store like the whole idea
of like Wally West's and and company and
so on and so forth and so the cool thing
about this is what we do is we basically
pick up in the aftermath of the perfect
storm in the sense that with Gorilla
Grodd invading you know central city and
so on and so forth the city was almost
destroyed and so right now it's kind of
in shambles and people are basically
picking up the pieces and that's really
kind of where things reside now with the
flash family they're able to clear up a
lot of this stuff pretty fast but it's
still kind of a thing that's going on in
the background the issue with this is
that what's been happening or at least
what went hat well what took place
during the events of the perfect storm
is that Barry Allen freed godspeed and
he did that because he needed God's
pete's help and the help of all the
speedsters to defeat Gorilla Grodd and
so because of this when the when I guess
the investigation is being done the
question is how did god speed get out
now of course Barry doesn't spill any
secrets because one need has to reveal
his identity as a flash to his partner
and two it would begin to ask questions
on whether or not he's actually capable
of doing his job effectively and
Kristen's not really in the note when it
comes to that kind of stuff as far as
she's aware she's just there with Barry
Allen and that's really about it but god
speeds kind of like the big catch right
like that's the big one like the big
baddie it's almost kind of like a newer
iteration of reverse flash that we can
see a little more consistently than we
do with the reverse flash character but
the idea here is that we basically pick
up you know following that whole
investigation and that that little bit
of a revelation by Barry we end up
picking up with the idea of like Avery
how speaking with young Wally West's now
remember Avery Howe is one of these
characters that was hit with the Speed
Force storm during the original god
speed story that we covered which I'll
have the link of the description you're
welcome to check that out but the idea
was that there was this massive Speed
Force storm and a whole bunch of people
got Speed Force powers and what this was
is it was a way and and DC will do this
occasionally it was a way for Joshua
Williamson to basically give speedster
powers to everybody and then essentially
go through and start eliminating people
and then give us a couple new speedsters
but for Avery Howe the reason why you
haven't really seen her in the flash
stories is because what they did is once
she went to like the kind of an Academy
of sorts and learned how to harness her
abilities she was ushered off to Justice
League China and it was a really cool
idea it was very similar to the idea of
like Justice League International right
like you had the original Justice League
team from 1960 that was cancelled 25
years later in 1985 and then we got
Justice League International post-crisis
which was Batman and basically people
who couldn't sell their own comics and
so the result is that it you know with
the Justice League of China they're
actually selling pretty well and it's an
amazing story I don't know how many of
you guys are reading like new Superman
but it's really really cool it's a
really really fun story but having a
speedster on that team actually works
out really really well now calling her
in for this whole thing is a way to kind
of bring her back in and remind us she's
still very much a part of the flash
family but that's why she's basically
been out of the picture for most of this
stuff the other half of this is that the
the new 52 you wally west kind of seems
to have a thing for it so it makes sense
I mean they're just two young kids but
still from here we pick up with probably
the most important part of this story
and this is the conversation that takes
place between Wally Barry and iris now
iris knows Barry's the flash the issue
with that is in a lot of ways Barry has
consistently put himself in a position
where it's like I try to protect people
around me by keeping that part of myself
hidden but the problem here is that very
Alan in the flash and even iris goes as
far as to say it you're you're the flash
you're not Batman you know you're not
you don't have to pretend to be two
distinctly different people the flash
does what he does because you are the
flash because the flash does what you
would do because you do those things I
mean it you know it's it's a core part
of who you are and it's interesting
because as they go through and they
start to have this conversation he
reveals a flash soon you know and it
kind of brings all that stuff out to her
what she wants to know is who the flash
is about what the flash believes how the
flash sees the world and it's kind of
cool because when you look at the
character of iris West for the most part
she's on the outside looking in you know
you have a reporter and she sticks to
her guns the only kind of good stuff and
you've got Barry Allen who's running
around on his escapades and so on and so
forth but she'll never be a speedster
like she'll never really be a member of
the flash family insofar as actually
having SuperSpeed that's so because that
trying to sort of blend these two things
together and get a much stronger and
better feel for who Barry is this is a
conversation that's been long and
waiting and the other cool thing about
this this is one of the cool things I
loved about Joshua Williamson writing is
that the question she asks is
what does what is a flash listen to when
he runs and we end up fighting out of
they listens to Neil deGrasse Tyson
which is kind of cool
he listens to audiobooks while he runs
but yeah so this is this is a
conversation that's been long and
waiting and it's awesome because they
just kind of profess their love for each
other and that's really what in a lot of
ways fans have been waiting for it's one
thing for Irish to know that Barry's the
flash is another for her to know about
Barry and all that kind of good stuff
but this kind of seems like a throwback
to the way things should be in the sense
that it's the two of them together you
know both halves of them kind of coming
together and essentially making this
cohesive whole that's very much
reminiscent of the old flash stories
that so many fans grew up with and so
what ends up happening is you basically
have Barry who simply says like this is
the next step the other thing I've done
here is I've brought somebody else and
Wally West steps in now remember ever
since Wally West showed back up in DC
rebirth he's and he's really avoided
Iris as often as he can because remember
Wally West is one of the only people
probably the only person who really
truly fully knows what's going on with
regards to the fact that someone stole
time for everybody's lives presumably
dr. Manhattan you know that all those
things were going on and so because of
this when he looks at iris West he
basically looks at a person that he's
known for years and years and years out
of his life
ever since he was a little kid but she
didn't really know who he was and if he
stepped into that role and said hey like
I'm Wally West and I'm your nephew you
know and we've been family for so long
if she doesn't know who he is
that would be crushing it was a way for
Wally West to kind of live in isolation
to go back to his position as being the
flash but avoid all the terrible things
that would come that would come along
with essentially turning people's lives
upside down because maybe iris would
have remembered
but what if she rebuked him what if she
was just like no no no I don't want to
know any of this I want things to go
back the way they were before that's
what he was dealing with and that's what
he's dealing with now like when he's
here and when he starts to talk to her
she um you know he immediately turns
away he's just kind of I can't do this
we need to go somewhere else and iris
stops them and says I know who you are
you're Wally West and this is amazing
because for those fans again for those
fans who grow up with the flash a little
bit a little bit of a fun fact here a
lot of fans who are into into the comics
right now who grew up with the flash
they grew up with Wally West post-crisis
with Mike Barron and Mark Waid and Grant
Morrison and Jeff Jones if you were
reading flash comics you were reading
Wally West that's just the way it was
and so when you had fans who were
watching like you know Justice League
and Justice League Unlimited
so on and so forth and they were
watching the flash they were following
Wally West and a lot of fans got really
attached to that and the result was that
when classic Wally West was wiped away
fans lost it because they felt like they
had lost a huge part of their life and
so with that in mind like seeing this
take place seeing this kind of
reconciliation with iris West
remembering Wally Wally you know
basically sort of coming back to a life
that he's missed for so long it's kind
of a beautiful thing for for older fans
to see you know if we're fans of comics
to see because what this means is that
even if it's not all here it means that
pieces are slowly starting to click in
place that it's a slow game that is
basically Williamson giving us light
this little piece here and this little
piece there and it all kind of comes
together in this huge return of the
flash mythos as so many fans know it and
so what ends up going on is iris asked
the question where's everybody else and
that's the important thing here that is
the important thing
because Wally remembers Linda Park Wally
doesn't remember Jai he doesn't remember
iris so at least there's no indication
that he remembers his kids and that's
kind of funny because Geoff Johns
tweeted out why does it want to remember
his kids and Williamson just immediately
throws us in here now I mean I'm not
saying once correlated to the other but
it is kind of a cool idea because when
the question is asked it's like we as
fans say yeah where is as we're as kids
at how come he hasn't said anything to
Linda Park yet like like do that and
that's iris this question where's Linda
where's Jai where's iris where where is
everyone and then suddenly all of
Wally's memories just start kicking in
and he simply just says like I remember
everything so what this indicates is
that when Wally first showed up in BC
rebirth he only remembered as much you
know only a handful of things but now
like all these memories are pouring back
his time is part of the Teen Titans his
time facing offer August meeting eobard
thawne for the first time
Winnie married Linda Park when he first
got his powers presumably when he and
Linda had giant iris they had his kids I
remember everything about all this stuff
I moved my whole life and this is
awesome because what this is is this
Joshua Joshua Williamson opening the
floodgates and saying okay it's only a
matter of time before everything comes
back if you were concerned that you
wouldn't see Jay Garrick anymore after
the button if you were concerned that
you're never gonna see max mercury if
you're concerned that you're never gonna
see Johnny and Jesse chambers then let
me put those concerns to bed you're
probably gonna see those characters come
back which is a welcoming thing because
what it means is we'll have this
speedster family which now is about
three or four people it's gonna explode
up and probably end up with about ten so
we're gonna have like this massive you
know sort of return of all these
different speakers and this huge fly
mythos returning to the way that it was
before DC rebooted everything back in
2011 but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here too comments explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rod core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace